le cinéma était l'un de nos grands
sujets de conversation sur ce point
alexandre astruc daniel gélin horrifiant
roger vadim était absolument interdit
sable nous assistions comme de bons
petits soldats aux trois séances de la
cinémathèque de la ville de messine et
après ça on se précipiter au bar vers
pour en discuter
le bar vers c'est une ancienne boucherie
bien gardé les grilles derrière nous
continuons nos discussions comme ça
pendant des heures et des heures et
quand le bar vers fermées après que nous
ayons bu du café au lait ce qui était
une chose plus rare à cette époque on se
retrouvait sur le trottoir et la
continuer la conversation et le ton
montait le ton monte parce que nous
discutions de choses aussi graves que
les mérites comparés de messieurs murnau
fritz lang ou je travaille mais vraiment
le ton monte très très haut et très fort
et évidemment les braves gens qui
habitaient cette truqués la rue jacob
ont commencé de s'impatienter nous
verser sur la tête c'était proto salles
et autres choses de ce genre ce qui
n'était pas tellement plaisant si nous
sommes ce n'atténue en rien notre envie
de continuer en discussion mais ce n'est
pas très agréable de tenir salon dans un
ruisseau autre manière or un soin que
j'avais été copieusement arrosée par les
habitants extrêmement mécontents de la
rue jacob
je rentrais chez moi me changer escorté
mes camarades et en passant par la rue
dauphine 9e une agitation fébrile on se
demande pourquoi c'était l'heure à
laquelle les camionneurs des messageries
achète commence la diffusion de leurs
journaux ils avaient ils avaient leur
dépôt dans une rue adjacente et au coin
de cette rue et de la rue dauphine
il y avait un petit bar un petit bar qui
s'appelait le tabou appeler sans doute
comme cela par par l ancien marin qui
avait
qu'elle ait connu là polynésie et là il
y avait du café chaud décroissance qui
était fort à cette époque nous hantera
qui peut intriguer devant le comptoir il
y avait quatre de ces camionneurs à
table est extrêmement cossu et qui
portait des canadiennes fourré notre
rêve à tous vos rêves irréalisables et
derrière le bar il y avait les
propriétaires de cet endroit lui était
un tout petit mais minuscule c'était un
des plus petit couple que j'ai vu
j'étais là derrière comme des
marionnettes lui avait des cheveux bruns
et friesi qui dépassait à peine le
comptoir et ils étaient d'anciens
commissaires kg et écouter la
conversation et elle elle était blonde
et avec des cheveux aussi assez serré
valade est friable du solide et elle
était ancienne choriste une capitale de
toulouse évidemment corps d ouvrir la
bouche nous comprîmes tout de suite
qu'elle était l'air de riches c'était
des gens charmants il s'appelait
monsieur et madame guyon de l'est et
depuis
depuis nous sommes toujours retourner au
tabou